the unemployment rate here in las vegas
has now dropped to 18 percent that is
according to the state department of
employment
for the month of june las vegas was
still 14
though below job levels a year ago
statewide jobs were about 10 percent
lower than june of last year
the nevada unemployment rate was 15 that
is half of the
staggering 30 percent we were at in
april
well so many nevadans are looking for
work right now as we report on those
numbers and fashion show mall is helping
people get a fresh start i'm bianca
holman there live with what's going on
hi bianca
hey good morning alex some people may be
thinking i need a head shot to find a
job well there are so many job sites
like linkedin where they require
you to upload a picture and those
snapchat and instagram filters no no
they just won't do
you need to bring in a professional like
mondo uh
also like josh these are two local
photographers that have
teamed up with fashion show las vegas to
help so many people
looking for opportunities so esther
she's with fashion show las vegas tell
us what you all have going on here today
we are so excited about this partnership
it's nationwide partnership with
headshot booker
where we're offering over 10 000
headshots across the country in over 50
states
here at fashion show we are offering
this partnership with josh line
where we're offering complimentary
headshots to
local las vegas residents who really
need that jump start and are impacted by
unemployment due to the state of our
climate today so we're excited to offer
this today
you can book your appointment at
headshotbooker.com
where you can secure your spot and make
sure that you come down to fashion show
the shop dine with us and also take
advantage of the chance to receive a
complimentary
headshot for you to get a jump start in
your career search
why was this so important to do i mean
so many people are struggling right now
looking for opportunities this isn't
going to make a difference well the
founder of headshot booker
tony tafe really experienced this
because his father
went through unemployment and so their
family struggled
so with that in mind he started this
company and we at fashion show we are
local we believe in being part of the
community and together we will get
through this
we have safety measures in place we have
cleaning protocols in place so we
encourage you to come
here to fashion show shop with us and
receive a complimentary headshot
all right so people that are watching
this they're getting up this morning
they're probably doing their hair and
makeup they're like okay girls
let me sign up where do i sign up i know
lots of slots have filled up fast but
there still are some available right
hashtagbooker.com secure your spot we're
here from 10
to 7 pm today beautiful all right we're
definitely going to have this
information posted for you all
back to you all in the studio good